weißt du wieviel zucker du am tag ist es
ist mehr als du denkst denn lebensmittel
industrie und politik tun viel dafür
dass du es nicht erfährt
ich halte zucker für die volksgesundheit
ob auch für den einzelnen für
schädlicher als auch aber das problem
ist halt an diesen blöden zucker er ist
halt einfach auch lecker
zucker ist nicht ungefährlich die zahl
der diabetes zwei erkrankten steigt
drastisch und so werden menschen zu
leidtragenden einer politik die das
wohlergehen der lebensmittelindustrie
vor den ihrer bürger ihnen stellt die
glaube ich spiele ganz brutal mit der
gesundheit der menschen ich bin noch
ziemlich sicher dass jetzt alle
haargenau wissen
so glauben wir sieht unser essen heute
aus super food lokal und kliniken
doch so sieht es wirklich aus zucker
über zucker denn tatsächlich der
zuckerkonsum der deutschen hat sich in
den letzten 50 jahren kaum verändert
35 kilogramm essen die deutschen
durchschnittlich im jahr
mein name ist andreas laufer ich bin 36
jahre alt wenn es mir nicht gut geht und
ich es irgendwie was etwas
zuckerhaltiges schokolade irgendwelche
süßigkeiten dann werden glückshormone
freigesetzt die gegen das schlechte
gefühl in mir ankämpfen
wie andreas laufer geht es vielen von
uns zucker ist lecker tut erst mal gut
und aufgrund komplizierter
nährwertkennzeichnung kann er sich in
mehr produkten verstecken als wir denken
zum beispiel im gekochten schinken
gewürzgurken oder ketchup was nebenher
passiert fast unbemerkt passiert ist
dass wir uns gewöhnen an einen gewissen
grad an süße die lebensmittel haben
und wenn ein produkt dies dann nicht
mehr enthält dann schmeckt es für uns
plötzlich fahrt tatsächlich geht es
einfach nur darum etwas in die produkte
hinein zu geben was die produkte süße
macht was den geschmack insgesamt
verstärkt auch deshalb hat der zucker
eine so große lobby er ist eine art
wunderwaffe für die
lebensmittelindustrie
er macht lebensmittel nicht nur süßes
sondern auch haltbarer beispiel ketchup
heinz tomato ketchup keine modifizierte
stärke oder konservierungsmittel
das liegt unter anderem auch daran dass
zucker eben ein teil dieser funktion
übernehmen kann
der zucker ist neben dem geschmacklichen
beitrag beitrag der zur stabilität des
produktes zu seinem seiner textur dem
aussehen aber eben auch zur haltbarkeit
beiträgt und ganz schön billig für den
hersteller ist er außerdem auch der
zuckerpreis in der europäischen union
ist seit juli 2017 beispiellos
abgestürzt von über 500 euro auf einen
preis von 375 euro pro tonne
wenn man sich anschaut welche
gewinnmargen welche umsatzrendite mit
welcher art von lebensmittelprodukt zu
erzielen ist dann kann man feststellen
dass die umsatzrendite die sich mit
süßigkeiten mit eiscreme mit limonaden
erzielen lässt mindestens dreimal so
hoch ist wie die umsatzrenditen die sie
mit obst oder gemüse beispielsweise
erzielen können er versteckt der zucker
ist gut für die lebensmittelindustrie
aber nicht für unsere gesundheit was
erhöht der zuckerkonsum anrichten kann
spüren immer mehr junge menschen wie
auch andreas laufer
ich habe jetzt seit februar habe ich
diabetes typ 2 diabetes bleibt meist
lang unentdeckt
die gefahr tatsächlich dass man den
diabetes nicht richtig greifen und
spüren kann und dass ein erhöhter
blutzucker nicht wehtut
das kann zu durchblutungsstörungen
kommen schäden an gefäßen die dann
wieder zu herzinfarkten schlaganfällen
führen könnt die entschädigungen
schädigung des augenhintergrund
schädigung der durchblutung gerade auch
in den beinen und auch nervenschäden
sind die häufigsten folgen die lobby
leugnet den einfluss von zucker auf
diabetes-erkrankungen zitat es gibt
keinen wissenschaftlichen beleg dafür
dass einzelne nährstoffe wie zb zucker
für die entstehung von übergewicht und
nicht übertragbaren krankheiten wie
diabetes mellitus typ 2 verantwortlich
sind
fest steht aber zu viel zucker macht
dick über 90 prozent der diabetes typ 2
erkranken sind übergewichtig
gesüßte getränke fruchtjoghurt
convenience food auch da ist einfach
viel versteckter zucker drin
mittlerweile ist die ernährungsindustrie
der zweitgrößte exporteur der
europäischen union
die deutsche süßwarenindustrie
exportiert weltweit am meisten 2010
diskutierte die europäische union über
die einführung einer ampelkennzeichnung
daraus wurde nichts
man sagt ja das sagen die die seite die
das verhindern wollte fast eine
milliarde euro in einem kampagne
gesteckt hat um die
lebensmittelkennzeichnung zu verhindern
mit hilfe einer einheitlichen ampel
hätten die konsumentinnen den gehalt an
nährstoffen wie fett salz und zucker
schnell und leicht verständlich ablesen
können
es ging fast ausschließlich darum ein
modell zu verhindern dass auf der
vorderseite mit klaren farben rot gelb
grün auf einen blick erkennbar gemacht
hätte wie denn die nährwert qualität
eines produktes zu sehen ist wann immer
wir zu gesprächen mit abgeordneten nach
brüssel gefahren sind muss mehr erleben
die lebensmittelindustrie war schon dort
mehrfach hat sie stände aufgebaut im
gebäude des europaparlaments man muss
sich das vorstellen
die automobilindustrie macht einen stand
im bundestag es gäbe einen riesigen
aufschrei im europaparlament ist das
möglich
[Musik]
das ist nicht der profis muskelfleisch
wien das sich vorstellen aber es wird
ganz gezielt mit subtilen methoden
versucht ein politisch zu beeinflussen
wir haben ja auch eine menge mitarbeiter
werbedienst die werden auch direkt
bearbeitet werden auch schon eingeladen
schwitzt und dann auch freundlich in den
arm genommen
wir haben wirklich gelernt dass wir bei
der lobbyarbeit nicht im ansatz
mithalten können die industrie hat ein
dichtes lobbyistinnen netz um das
europaparlament gespannt und die
verbraucher innen die vertritt in
brüssel nur eine einzige organisation
der verbraucherschutzverband boc deren
chefin kämpft gegen ganze heerscharen
von industrie lobbyistinnen und hier
haben wir die lebensmittelabteilung des
europäischen verbraucher verbandes zwei
personen momentan wir haben uns mal
ausgerechnet zur grobe also für ein
verbraucher lobbyist gibt es 100
industrie lowinski 2010 wurde auf eu
ebene mit 60 zu 40 gegen die
ampelkennzeichnung gestimmt
verglichen mit den möglichkeiten der
verbraucher innen und der deutlich
kleineren lobby ein sehr knappes
ergebnis
heute wird immer noch über eine
lebensmittelampel gestritten
wir haben zehn jahre verloren muss man
eindeutig sagen zehn jahre haben die
anderen da hat die zuckerwatte zucker
und süßwarenindustrie jetzt gewonnen um
weiter die produkte auf den markt zu
bringen und mehr unabhängigkeit zu
bringen eine verantwortung die die lobby
von sich weist
die diskussion über den zucker in den
letzten jahren ist deutlich angeheizt
worden durch ganz viele verschiedene
vorschläge von zucker besteuerung über
neue etiketten gestaltungen bis hin zu
anderen einschränkungen ich bin davon
überzeugt dass der deutsche verbraucher
sich letztlich nicht allzusehr
bevormunden lässt dennoch die
bundesregierung schafft nun die
rechtlichen grundlagen für die
lebensmittelkennzeichnung nur trikot mit
einem haken er bleibt freiwillig auch
deshalb weil geltendes eu-recht eine
national verpflichtende kennzeichnung
eben nicht vorsieht deutschland könnte
das ändern
hat es doch seit diesem jahr die eu
ratspräsidentschaft inne
aber kritiker innen bemängeln die
fehlende leidenschaft der zuständigen
ministerin julia klöckner für eine
verpflichtende regelung
immer wieder wird ihr nähe zu
lebensmittelindustrie vorgeworfen
und deshalb freue ich mich dass wir uns
heute über die philosophie von wesley
unterhalten haben
support viel neues erfahren und freue
mich dass wir unterstützung haben
der preis für den übermäßigen
zuckerkonsum ist hoch
wir müssen diese gesamtrechnung dringend
auf machen dass wir sagen können okay
vielleicht ist die freiheit des
einzelnen wichtig aber du weißt genau
wenn du zu viel konsumiert dann
kriegszeit irgendwann probleme mit
deiner gesundheit diese kosten bezahlt
den gesamtgesellschaft laut schätzungen
werden zehn prozent der
gesundheitsausgaben für diabetes und
folgeerkrankungen ausgegeben die
gesetzlichen krankenkassen sollen 2019
mehr als 24 milliarden euro ausgegeben
haben
wenn ich davor schon ein bisserl
umsichtiger damit umgegangen wäre dann
hätte es vielleicht vermeiden können
aber ich habe es halt nicht gemacht und
habe auch nie irgendwelche gedanke daran
verschwendet eine frage der abwägung von
gesundheit der bürger innen und
wohlergehen der lebensmittelindustrie
wir brauchen eine bundesregierung die
bereit ist auch gegen die interessen der
lebensmittelindustrie der
lebensmittelwirtschaft entscheidungen zu
treffen dann wenn es nämlich dem
gesundheitsschutz der menschen dient und
der gesellschaft insgesamt dient findet
ihr die politik sollte mehr gegen die
gefahren von zucker unternehmen schreibt
es uns in die kommentare